so after a day of a fair amount of
confusion a heavy dose of speculation it
remains best to go straight to the
source
we got to see from the president
directly last night and our next guest
has known the man
for decades and spoke to the president
yesterday
let's bring in rudy giuliani presidents
trump's attorney and former new york
city mayor and the host
of rudy giuliani's common sense podcast
good morning rudy thanks for being here
we know you spoke to the president
yesterday on the phone um
how is he feeling how did he sound
well i mean on the phone he sounded like
himself completely i mean we had
about a 35-40 minute conversation some
of it of course about his health i was
very concerned about him
i was very happy to hear his voice
sounding exactly the same as
i've known her for 30 years and then
after we talked about his health
we started to talk about politics and he
gave me a lot of notes
to give to the campaign about what they
should do and how they should do it and
even wrote out a kind of speech
i had to kind of get him off the phone
so we went back and rested
and he did say that he'd love to get out
as quickly as possible he feels like
he'd go out now
he said he felt pretty bad the first day
but now he feels for the last 24 hours
and that was three o'clock yesterday he
felt perfectly fine no fever
a little tired but not very tired for
him to be a little tired is nothing
so i i uh foresee i've been had several
friends that have been through this
some much worse and they've they've
gotten through and they're fine now and
he's
he's probably the strongest and
healthiest guy i know anywhere near his
age
well that's very good news to hear rudy
and another question on everyone's mind
is how are you feeling uh we know that
you were in
that debate prep room uh chris christie
was in that room as well we know that he
has now
tested positive and checked himself into
a hospital as
a cautious measure but are you okay and
have you been tested
yeah i have been tested as tested two
days ago i'll get tested again
probably tomorrow i have no symptoms
uh chris was on my right and kellyanne
was on my left
oh gosh for about four hours and two
different days and the president of
course was in front of me when we were
doing it
and then i was on the airplane with him
and then i saw him again on
wednesday afternoon last time i saw him
was wednesday about 2 15
before he was taking off for the uh for
the rally
i have to tell you like joe said before
you could have knocked me down when i
heard that he that he had covert on
friday morning he looked
he looked perfect and he looked really
good so these things are strange and how
can
how can you explain it chris here
kellyanne there
they both have it and i uh right now i
don't so
you just don't know and i think the
thing the president i think wants people
to know is
we've got to face up to this illness we
can't i mean he he could have chosen to
go
hide somewhere in the white house for
five months uh particularly
you know uh since this it's pretty nice
there and you can communicate from there
but he said i couldn't do that i had i
had to cautiously
start to go out and lead the way back if
i didn't lead who was going to lead
if i stayed holed up there the whole
economy would stay hold up
uh and my god i really relates that
because that's why i felt on september
11.
i felt like i had to get out in front i
had a lead the city was going to take a
little while to come back
and maybe i was taking a little risk in
getting them to come out so fast and
work down there but life's got to go on
we we have to live with risk we have to
teach our children that
there's i mean i didn't get covered but
god forbid something else could happen
to me in
20 minutes you don't stop living and
covid now is treatable
and kovitt now is at a at a mortality
fatality whichever
rate which is uh within within the norm
for for a serious illness so it's no
longer what it was
four or five months ago and if we act
like four or five months ago we were all
hiding behind
chairs and have big mass on all the time
uh gosh our economy will never get going
so wear a mask
cleanse your hands be careful but don't
be paralyzed please please
our economy has to come back and for the
good of our children we get this economy
back
and we assert ourselves as the most
powerful nation on earth because
otherwise you know who will
the country that attacked us china and
they attacked us
believe me yeah i hold them responsible
i hold them responsible for what
happened to my president yesterday
well it was day before yesterday and
everybody else
no it's a very important point uh mr
mayor great point and
you're you saying that you had to kick
the president off the phone after 40
minutes sounds about right
good information but you you you
mentioned uh leading
after uh after 9 11 uh unprecedented
times
uh and the president is channeling that
what's your what's your advice to him
having spoken to him about the next
couple of days going forward what action
should he be taking
at this moment do you think well
it's a little like a baseball player i
love baseball and you know baseball
players get injuries and sometimes they
come back too fast right pete and they
get
even football players then they get
really injured this is
this isn't going to be long we're
talking three to seven days
for a recovery but he should listen to
the doctor
uh and this is this is a chance for us
all of us who he's carried for
three and a half four years i mean we
watch this man and those of us who love
him and care about him
makes you want to cry to think of what
they've done to him every single day
he's been in the white house
they try to get him out from the day he
started until now
i mean last week nancy pelosi wanted to
impeach him because he nominated uh
judge
baron i mean him impeachment judge
barrett i mean
some of the others are just as stupid
they have tortured this man
and he's accomplished more than any
president that i can remember so maybe
he's entitled to a little rest and i
said to him
you've got a lot of friends they're all
calling me they all want to go out and
help you
you know we can't campaign as well as
you can but we can campaign
and i think that's something that's been
sparked in the american people i think
it's like a friend that you take for
take advantage of or you take not take
advantage of it take take for granted
he's the friend we've been taking for
granted he's been carrying us now it's
time for all of us to carry him and
you're going to see this campaign fan
out all over the country and it's
probably going to have a lot more people
than it had before we've got more
volunteers in the last two days
then i don't know when maybe the first
day he announced
rudy as was mentioned at the beginning
of this segment you were involved in
debate prep for
the president you've been around him
through that debate prep uh the next one
on the schedule though is the vice
presidential debate
uh kamala harris is already out there uh
in utah ahead of her
debate i want you to listen to something
she had to say and then see if we can
get some advice from you on how mike
pence might prepare for this debate
listen to this
sure let's put our shoulders to the
wheel let's do the work that is
necessary
to continue to fight for our ideals and
our values and
in this case what they fought for
so many years ago which is for freedom
and
and to hold our country accountable for
the ideals we say we hold dear
so it's great to be here i'm really
honored to be here i'll be here for the
next
few days preparing for the debate and i
want to thank the people of utah for
being so welcoming
in such a warm way rudy this debate
between vice president pence and kamala
harris has got to be very different from
the one that took place
a week ago what would you see going
forward what advice would you give
well i think it's you know the vice
president is a terrific debater he's a
very very strong speaker he's really
smart i think he's gonna obviously he's
gonna point out
what the administ what the
administration has accomplished and also
i think most importantly we are having a
recovery
we're having a recovery that's better
than anybody expected i mean the guy the
guy who gave us the best economy
possible is giving us a recovery that's
five times faster
than all the experts predicted it would
be tragic to try to interrupt that
with somebody like kamala harris who
wants to have uh
i mean she's not gonna have any any any
problem with that whole green
thing there she'll have no problem at
all i mean she's big big in favor of it
she wants to raise taxes to about 60 70
percent
she endorses the entire socialist uh uh
program she's one of the authors of it
so i mean he's got he's got to point out
who she is
she's a she's a very very massive
spending
socialist and then her record as
district attorney gee i'd love to take
that apart because i was a us attorney
she's one of those that i consider one
of the most disgraceful u.s attorneys
she put little people in jail and she
let b people go 1500
marijuana smokers and then a bunch and
then a bunch of big gangsters and gang
members went free
because she she couldn't convict anybody
so she went after the little people to
get statistics
i can pick that out in a second certain
number of prosecutors like that they're
usually
too ambitious and not very ethical so i
think he's got to go after and point out
who she is
this is a wolf in sheep's clothing this
is a true
socialist and given the fact that joe
biden
doesn't seem to be as kind as i can say
it
that sharp and gets pushed a little
i mean his positions change all the time
we don't know where his position is on
the green new deal
he was for it against it and now he's
slightly for it she endorsed it
[Laughter]
endorsed it and a four trillion dollar
tax increase
four trillion dollar attack and another
three trillion dollars for that
that's a socialist pete that's a that's
a true absolutely
socialist and that rudy i'm just curious
i'm just curious if you've i don't want
to interrupt but we i don't want to run
out of time
have you spoken to pence at all about
debate strategy as he heads into this
you know covet 19 is now going to be a
front and center issue at this debate
perhaps more than ever
i'm just curious if you've had any
conversations with him about strategy
how to approach that issue or anything
in general
a different team is preparing him i have
talked to him here and there but not
like in a formal sense
you know given the way he performed last
time and knowing him as well as i do
that there's no reason for the people
who who are doing it are are doing it
and both he and the president
they don't prepare like in a rehearsed
way they prepare
for questions and answers you know what
here's the answer did i get all the
facts in here are a few more facts well
maybe it's better to say it this way
it's a much more satisfying way to
prepare than sort of
kind of acting out acting out the debate
and i think it works uh
each time unfortunately we have to leave
it right there i can listen
talk to you all morning long you you
it's the guy who took on the box
and him amen absolutely yeah these guys
are nothing compared to their mob
nothing
mayor julian
thank you so much we appreciate it